so as a lot of you guys may have noticed
recently with all-new all-different
marvel I've been very heavy-handed in
terms of how I've looked at the line of
publications just because I'm such a
huge Marvel Comics fan and I think that
as comic book fans whether it's Marvel
DC value nor otherwise we have a
tendency to latch on to things and we
have a very difficult time you know
accepting when things move away from the
status quo or when we want things to
change and they don't really seem to
change and so it's almost kind of
interesting you know we have our heart
set on something you know we're told a
thing will happen in the future and we
build it up into something in our minds
and when the the result that we get is
not what we built it up to be then we
end up finding ourselves a little
disappointed and so with all-new
all-different marvel you know I'd been a
little overzealous in terms of my my
view of this line of publications and
the reason why I say that is I just
finished International Ironman and the
new secret origin of Tony Stark and damn
not gonna tell you guys
Bendis has not lost his touch Civil War
twos a little lackluster it feels a
little rushed but international Ironman
is quite literally Bendis sitting down
taking his time and writing a great
story so this new secret origin of Tony
Stark is basically rooted in the run of
Karen Gillan with Iron Man vol 5 now I
do have a video on the original secret
origin of Tony Stark but for those of
you guys who don't really want to watch
that video which you'll find in the
description and you simply want to know
what happened during Marvel now original
Marvel now marvel have come along and
they'd basically shaken things up a bit
it was kind of Marvel's response to DC's
new 52 reboot and it was the idea of
assigning new riders new artists to
titles and going back and fleshing out
storylines and flushing out plot threads
that had kind of been left hanging over
the years and so what writer Karen
Gillan did is he had followed up to the
entire extremis event whereby different
people were able to get their hands on
Tony Stark's armor so on so forth the
whole extremis event and what he did is
he basically had Tony Stark kind of
questioned his role in the world where
was he going you know what was what was
happening with his place as part of the
Avengers what was happening you know
with his place as part of the superhero
community coming out of civil war coming
out of siege Dark Reign so on and so
forth all these things that kind of put
Tony Stark in an existential crisis and
so Peter quill star-lord had basically
given Tony the opportunity to join the
guardians of the galaxy and just kind of
traverse the spaceways if for no other
reason than to clear his mind while he
was away from the planet Earth and so
this game is some really really cool
story so what it also did is it set
things up for Karen Gillan to come back
and to basically change the origin of
Tony because prior to what Karen Gillan
did Tony Stark was just the son of
Howard Stark you know his father had
died Tony had inherited the family
fortune he would he had been a genius
ever since he was a child and he had
basically gone on to become a successful
businessman you know with Stark
Industries and eventually became Iron
Man that was more or less his story and
it had been that way for 30 years it
always been that way that was just the
definitive origin what Karen Gillan did
is he came back and he basically said
that Tony Stark was effectively adopted
not only that Tony Stark actually had a
long-lost brother named Arno that he
didn't know about now again I'm not
gonna go super in-depth into this just
because I had a video that covers all
that but the fact remains here that that
Arno start was the biological child of
Howard and Maria Stark and that that
Tony was the adopted child now there
were a lot of things that went into our
know he had a disability he was kind of
hidden away from the world by Howard
ámoreá and Stark was adopted to kind of
take his place and it allowed for some
really good storytelling with regards to
the character of Arno and it was kind of
sad to see that with all-new
all-different marvel he essentially just
disappeared from the landscape but with
this new secret origin of 20 Stark what
Bendis does is he comes back and he kind
of fills in the holes he basically tells
us you know what was going on behind the
scenes you know leading up to the
adoption of Tony Stark and the events
that took place afterwards and what
we're told here is that at some point
along the line there was a woman named
Amanda strong and a man is strong was
was basically just a fledgling singer
she was trying to build up her own
career she was trying to turn her Turner
career into something that could make
for a huge musical group that would
allow her to just continue and follow
her passion for as long as no she was
able to pursue it but during one of her
performances that she was contacted by a
woman named Valentina
who was part of shield and so what she
wanted to do is they wanted to recruit
Amanda strong and they wanted her to
maintain the cover of being an
international singer but they wanted to
use this cover as a way to have her
carry out clandestine missions and so
you know if she went on tour for example
and she was in Spain she would carry out
missions in Spain if she was on tour and
she was in California she would carry
out missions in California and this
would work really well for she'll
because remember this was back during
point whereby shield had just sort of
begun to form and so for those of you
guys who who never saw my original
series on I guess my series on original
sin you know the early days of Nick Fury
so on and so forth I this story largely
dealt with the idea that somewhere along
the line Nick Fury had come across a guy
named woody McCord who had basically
been going through different dimensions
and you know the earth itself and just
staving off threats to the planet Earth
and Nick Fury took his place but Nick
Fury also worked alongside Howard Stark
to create shield and so this is around
that time period when shield has been
created I would say maybe within the
following ten years after that was done
easily the first decade or so but the
fact remains here that was Amanda strong
operating as an agent of shield as she
eventually countered I guess encountered
and you know met a man named Jude
now Jude was of course a fellow agent
but at the time they had to maintain
discretion they had to maintain their
their position as agents of shield while
also ensuring that the public didn't
know what was going on and so what had
happened between the two of them is that
over the course of a series of missions
they ended up in Germany together and
the idea was that a romance was
blossoming between the two of them the
issue was that they were also being
pursued by Hydra because again at the
time this deals with 1960s shield and so
this is still at an era when Hydra is
very much a part of the Marvel Universe
and it's still attacking shield they're
still considered to be you know the main
enemies now of course this is also the
time period whereby Captain America was
still frozen and so this is he's not
really part of the picture here but the
fact remains that with Amanda strong and
with Jude because they had begun to form
a relationship one another albeit being
shield agents they get dated for about
two or three years and so over the
course of this time this led to Amanda
strong becoming pregnant with Tony Stark
the problem with this was that Jude had
viewed this life you know the life of
being an agent as something that they
could but they could both escape from
and Amanda strong is saw it the same way
and so Amanda strongly actually quit her
position with shield simply saying that
because she had a child to raise now she
couldn't have this child in this life
she couldn't have the child you know as
part of shield where we constantly be
put in danger because they didn't know
if as an agent of shield that you know
she would come home one day and find her
child dead find her husband killed or
something along those lines and it was
easier to just walk away and
make herself a target with Jude on the
other hand his motivations were a little
different here about a week before Tony
Stark was due to be born Jude sat down
with Amanda strong and basically said
that he was a double agent working for
both Hydra and shield now in the in the
eyes of Jude he wasn't just a typical
double agent he wasn't intentionally
betraying shield and he wasn't
intentionally working for Hydra it just
kind of fell in that way and what I mean
here is while the two of them were
dating because of the fact that Amanda
strong was a SHIELD agent Hydra had come
after her and attempted to kill her and
so what you did is he went off and made
a side deal that he would provide Hydra
with information if Hydra would
basically leave Amanda and himself alone
if they would allowing the two of them
to go do their own thing and so over the
course of the two years that Amanda
strong and Jude had been together Jude
had basically been selling out agents of
shield he had been selling shield Intel
to Hydra which is one of the reasons why
I guess this is really kind of Bendis is
retcon it's one of the reasons why you
know shield had struggled so hard
against Hydra over the years and what I
mean by this is that if you go back and
you look over the history of shield or I
may end up doing you know a video on the
full chronological history of shield but
over the course you know in their early
days it always seemed as though Hydra
was one step ahead it always seemed as
though Hydra always had the edge on them
now Bendis isn't telling us that Jude is
the reason for this in fact bindus
really kind of hints at the idea that
Jude is one of multiple agents in shield
who were seeding information to Hydra to
say nothing of the fact that Hydra had
their own sleeper agents in shield
now of course shield have their own
sleeper agents in Hydra and it was
really reminiscent of the spy days
between the United States and Russia
during the Cold War but the fact remains
here that because of the fact that Jude
revealed himself to have been a double
agent working for Hydra and shield
Amanda strong hates this notion and the
reason why she hates this is because it
makes both herself and her child a
target for either Hydra or shield and so
what she does is she kills Jude now of
course she makes a call to shield under
the auspices of contacting her record
label and when shield arrives she tells
valentina to basically move the baby
into an adoption agency to do something
with it to make sure that it's going to
have a safe home the problem with this
is that shield isn't normally equipped
for this kind of circumstance and this
is where Howard and Maria stow
come into the equation at the beginning
of the story and this is one of the
reasons why I left this to the end
because I wanted to make sure to kind of
fit in chronologically with this video
but at the beginning of the story Brian
Michael Bendis established that Howard
Emery astark we're having a hard time
conceiving a child now this is where the
whole idea of Arno comes into the play
and in fact in the fact that Arno is
kind of engineered so to speak but the
fact remains here that Howard a Maria
we're having a difficult time conceiving
a child on their own and what's
interesting about this when it comes to
the concept of Arno is it seems like
Brian Michael Bendis is writing him out
of the entirety of the Marvel Universe
because if Arno was going to be part of
all-new all-different marvel he would
have been mentioned here but the issue
is that neither Howard normal Rhea make
reference to our know there's no
indication that he exists but because
you know and with Tony start being
adopted after Arno was born you would
think that if Arno did exist there would
be a reference to him but the fact that
there's not seems to indicate that
bindus has removed Arno stark in his
entirety from all-new all-different
marvel now there may have been something
that I missed I don't think I have I pay
pretty close attention to the current
run of Ironman and international Ironman
so I'm pretty sure that I haven't missed
that but it's entirely possible and if I
have a feel free to put a comment down
in the comment section let me know but
the result here is that because Amanda
wanted to give up her child because of
the fact that there Howard and Maria
wanted to wanted to have a child or on
their own the piece is just kind of fit
in by themselves you know it really just
worked out on its own and so when Howard
Stark was informed that Amanda was
wanting to get rid of her child and that
trues wanted to give it up for adoption
and wanted shield to find a place to put
it
Howard Stark simply adopted the baby on
his own now we did this covertly what he
did is he took the baby to an orphanage
or I guess baby was taken to an
orphanage in Bulgaria and then all the
records were removed with the exception
of the medical records of Amanda strong
and then Howard Stark more or less has
kind of eliminated the history of Tony
Stark in his entirety and then adopted
him as his own child giving him a
history and because Stark was a newborn
at the time no one out there really
would have questioned it and so this
just led into Tony Stark's life as we
know it within his traditional role in
Marvel Comics now the reason why this
was all brought on the reason why you
know bindus took this road was because
as part of international iron man and as
part of learning that he was adopted
Stark
more or less went on this quest to find
out his heritage to find out where he
came from to find out who is via
logical mother was and so after learning
this information from the woman who's
currently taking care of the orphanage
Tony Stark goes and finds Amanda strong
and the International iron man you know
secret origin of Tony Stark essentially
ends with him meeting his mother for the
first time his biological mother for the
first time in saying that he wants to
get to know her better now what Bendis
does is he also tells us this will be
continued an invincible Iron Man now I
don't know how far he'll get into it but
it seems as though he's going to take
more of a personal approach to Tony
Stark and he's going to give us more
emphasis on Tony Stark's personal life
after meeting his mother but again we
don't really know what direction things
are going to take you know with Marvel
now it's kind of hard to gauge you know
what they're going to do with individual
characters so much as it is easier to
figure out what they're going to do with
teams but if you guys enjoyed this video
let me know you know post a comment down
below let me know what you guys thought
of it I thought it was really cool you
know if you guys are new here to my
channel that make sure you hit the sub
button become part of the Rob port and
drop a like and yeah if you guys have
any questions that there are aspects
this didn't make a whole lot of sense to
you again post a comment and I'll answer
them the best I can but I will catch you
guys later peace
did you never
I am
[Music]